france info et france 24 présente
[Musique]
bonjour c'est l'heure du retrait pour la
france au mali la france et ses
partenaires engagés dans des missions de
lutte contre le terrorisme à savoir les
états participant à la task force
takouba ont pris la décision de retirer
leur présence militaire au mali
jamais depuis la guerre d'algérie paris
n'était resté investit aussi longtemps
militairement à l'étranger alors ou
bamako se tourner vers d'autres alliés
russes notamment quel bilan tirer de
l'opération
le sahel est il plus sûr qu'en 2013 ou
au contraire les groupes djihadistes
ont-ils désormais le champ libre et avec
quelles conséquences pour les
populations
on va tenter d'y répondre dans ce
nouveau numéro du monde dans tous ses
états votre rendez-vous géopolitique sur
france info et france 24 avec vous
aujourd'hui antoine glaser bonjour
bonjour journaliste et écrivain
spécialiste de l'afrique vous êtes
l'auteur du livre le piège africains de
macron c'est publié chez fayard mais
d'abord nayem rafraîchissez nous donc la
mémoire que s'est-il passé durant la
décennie écoulée au mali et bien en mars
2012 des rebelles touareg sont rejoints
par des djihadistes il peine prenne le
contrôle du nord mali des régions de
tombouctou de kidal et 2 go en janvier
2013 à la demande des autorités
maliennes elle l'armée française
intervient et tentent d'arrêter ces
colonnes de djihadistes qui se dirige
vers la capitale bamako frappes
aériennes 4000 hommes au sol c'est le
début de l'intervention française au
mali l'opération serval un an plus tard
en 2014 elle devient l'opération barkan
jusqu'à 5000 hommes sont déployés son
coût 800 millions d'euros par an pendant
ces neuf ans de guerre est bien plus de
50 soldats français ont perdu la vie
après un nouveau coup d'état l'état le
reste aux mains des militaires maliens
le mali en train de laser qui a mobilisé
jusqu'au 3/4 des forces françaises
déployées à l'étranger pourquoi y avoir
investi autant de moyens belle idée
l'idée c'était un certain moment de et
c'est vrai que quand c'était un peu dans
une forêt c'est du temps de françois
hollande et à partir du moment où la
france il faut savoir sa diplomatie
d'influencé quand il dans cette région
jusqu'à présent qu elle est influente
aux nations unies grâce à ces opérations
de maintien de la paix mais aussi aux
opérations militaires et donc il y avait
une certaine volonté compte tenu de la
de la superficie de c'est un engagement
majeur le seul problème c'est que comme
on le verra autant l'opération serval en
2013 a été applaudi rappelez-vous
françois hollande ses plus beaux jours
de ma vie politique
autant l'opération barkan apparaît de
plus en plus maintenant un peu comme une
erreur ça veut dire une sorte de
consensus en disant qu' après serval la
france aurait dû et barkan après
l'éviction de ibrahim boubacar kéita
aurait dû retirer ses troupes et laisser
les maliens avec d'autres forces de la
région mais gérer leurs affaires et oui
malgré cet investissement massif cette
présence lui était devenue intenable
après l'expulsion d'un master de france
oui parce qu'en fait on voit bien que
c'est un peu une sorte d'armé
conventionnelle et on voit que ça ne
correspond absolument pas à la réalité
de la lutte antiterroriste je veux dire
on voit bien que la france va éliminer
des djihadistes mais avec des forces
beaucoup trop conventionnel qui est
drapeau français ça rappelle beaucoup
trop la françafrique d'une certaine
période de la guerre froide et on voit
bien que la maintenant pourquoi
finalement ya un retraite par cannes
bien sûr il ya le problème aussi avec la
junte malienne entre les pouvoirs
français la jeune malienne mais il ya
surtout franchement même dans les
milieux militaires off ils disent c'est
vrai qu' on aurait dû abandonner soit la
mort d'awk d'elle soit après l'élection
ibrahim boubacar kéita on aurait dû à un
moment donné passer à autre chose et en
même temps et dire regardez les russes
eux ils font tout à bas bruit c'est ce
qu'on aurait dû faire personne ne parle
par exemple de l'opération sabre dans la
banlieue de ouagadougou qui l'opération
des forces spéciales françaises au
burkina faso et au burkina faso qu'il
faut de la lutte anti jihadistes on les
entend pas on n'entend pas parler
pourtant ils sont extrêmement actifs
mairie car depuis 2013 le climat vous
l'avez compris a bien changé les
manifestations d'hostilité envers la
france se multiplient en témoignent ces
images tournées à bamako par cyril payen
c'était le 5 février et diffusé dans
l'émission reporter sur france 24
[Musique]
tél
l'eia
[Applaudissements]
on en compte un sentiment de fierté
sentiment de patriotisme qui m'a même
demandé comme ça vraiment je suis frères
maliens et des peuples africains
[Applaudissements]
ce au sénat
ah ah
le cortège de plusieurs milliers de
manifestants 20 pendant de longues
heures faire le tour de la ville en
gonflant ses rangs
[Musique]
une réussite totale à la bonne affaire
aucun entraîneur toute allure le mali
menaces en tout cas moi je
[Musique]
n'entends ces slogans nazis rabat la
france il ya un risque aujourd'hui pour
les français encore présents au mali
militaires comme civils non je pense pas
je l'aï font vraiment la différence sera
le pouvoir politique mais c'est vrai que
moi je suis vraiment surpris de voir on
a l'impression qu'on vit une sorte de
l'anachronisme historique ça veut dire
c'est vraiment une période initiale soit
si on reste le nez dans le guidon on
pense simplement une rapport à un
rapport de barkan des militaires
français avec le pouvoir malien mais à
mon avis il faut aller au delà il ya
vraiment une question de
d'anachronismes historique c'est une
période c'est un islam qui est en train
de se radicaliser dans toute la région
et le sentiment anti français on a
l'impression qu'on vit une période post
coloniale alors que normalement la fin
de la guerre froide 190 on a
l'impression que 20 ans après
l'impression qu'à une sorte de
souverainisme de nationalisme parmi la
jeunesse africaine qui va qui va
d'ailleurs de bamako mais vous aussi les
diasporas ici des gens qui sont mal en
exil considère que la france soutient
leur autocrate honnêtement il faut voir
ça avec un grand angle un avis pas ça
c'est pas simplement le problème du mali
c'est un problème de période historique
de changement profond dans toute cette
zone sahélo-saharienne est justement un
convoi militaire français avait été pris
à partie fin novembre du burkina faso
jusqu'au niger csn elle pourrait se
reproduire au mali dans le cadre du
repli français il ya toujours un danger
ceci dit je veux dire la base française
est à gao et à ménaka très proche du
niger apparemment le président mam et
bazou semble prêt à coopérer avec les
militaires français il ya sait déjà où
niger vous avez des des drones et des
drones et et tout à toute la partie
aérienne
de la présence militaire française donc
je veux dire c'est vrai que c'est
compliqué je fais pas un spécialiste
militaire j'ai pas vous dire des vrais
quand discale du militaire certains vous
18 mois de 12 mois etc mais très
honnêtement c'est c'est pas le problème
de fond il n'est pas là le problème
c'est que très honnêtement les
djihadistes ils ont réussi à faire fuir
les occidentaux depuis via la mauritanie
jusqu'au soudan y'a pas il ya plus de
sociétés civiles occidental ou française
il ya plus que les militaires français
c'est pour ça que les militaires
français barkan était totalement hors
sol par rapport aux réalités il ya plus
de wenzhou ya plus de coopération
décentralisée
il ya plus de présence occidentale donc
il ya une islamisation c'est vraiment
une page historique c'est je vais pas
dire que c'est un retour au 19e siècle
mais il ya quelque chose qui se passe au
delà même des diatribes france
françafrique à la france qui était venu
on s'en souvient il ya neuf ans pour
protéger les populations sahéliennes des
groupes crapuleux et djihadistes neuf
ans plus tard comment vit-on ce retrait
à bamako vous vous trouvez pour france
24 à 9 heures lespiau
bonjour a fait lille si l'heure est à
l'incertitude la population malienne
comme la communauté expatriée ou encore
la classe politique s'interroge sur les
conséquences du départ des troupes
françaises au mali au sein de la
population malienne bamako beaucoup se
félicite du départ de barkan au profit
de nouveaux partenaires comme la russie
la chine ou encore la turquie beaucoup
ici condamne les propos des autorités
françaises à l'égard des autorités de
transition ces derniers mois il prône la
construction d'un mali nous voient d'un
mâle et souverain sans la france la
france à qui ils reprochent son
ingérence dans la politique malienne
la plupart salue également la montée en
puissance de l'armée malienne qui depuis
quelques semaines adopté une posture
beaucoup plus offensive sur le terrain
et aurait permis affirme-t-elle
notamment dans le centre du mali
épicentre du conflit ici le
rétablissement de la sécurité dans
certaines localités d'autres espèrent
que le départ de la france permettra
d'entamer officiellement des
négociations avec les groupes
djihadistes qui contrôle aujourd'hui les
deux tiers du territoire qui échappe
depuis des années au contrôle de l'état
du côté de la population dans le nord du
mali qui est elle directement impactés
par le conflit quelles seront les
répercussions dans les mois à venir
le départ de l'armée française quelle
sera la posture des groupes djihadistes
face au vide laissé par barkan beaucoup
de questions qui restent aujourd'hui
sans réponse tous les scénarios sont
possibles dont celui du ko dont
s'inquiètent certains au sein de la
classe politique qui craignent je cite
dans le pire des cas que le mali
devienne le prochain afghanistan
le prochain afghanistan antoine glaser
et déjà dit ce qu' il ne faut pas
l'oublier se combattent entre les
affrontements entre le gsm l'ex aqmi al
qaïda au maghreb islamique eda r
absolument mais il faut savoir que ça va
passer quelque chose la vraie divergence
entre la france et la junte malienne
s'est pas dit ça qu'il y ait un peu dans
le reportage chez que finalement la
junte malienne ils veulent négocier avec
monsieur ya trafiqué le le chef du
groupe de soutien l'islam ou aux
musulmans
la france considère qu' il a du sang de
militaire française sur les mains donc
refusent ces négociations il ya l'italie
qui aussi qui joue un rôle un peu bon
c'est un pays européens et qui négocie
aussi avec un certain nombre de groupes
touareg avec lisant les accords d'alger
obtient un certain nombre de comm ca de
négociation qui ce qu'ils sont en train
de se faire et c'est vrai que ces
négociations il ya un vrai divergences
entre entre paris et la junte sur ce
problème là proprement dit ce retrait se
replie française sanctionne un échec
dans cette guerre asymétrique comment
expliquer qu'une force qui a compté
jusqu'à 5100 hommes sur place n'a pas pu
venir à bout du nez bulleuses jihadistes
et riz estimée entre 400 et 1 3001 très
franchement de m cinq mille hommes au
départ sur cinq millions de kilomètres
carrés c'était mission impossible
il y avait cent mille soldats cent mille
soldats américains en afghanistan sur
608 qui est le maître qu'à celle de la
france donc à un moment donné emmanuel
macron s'est rendu compte c'est mission
impossible pour les militaires il a
réduit sa la zone des trois frontières
entre le mali burkina et le niger donc
ça fait ça fait justement ces six cent
mille kilomètres carrés et le problème
de fond dans la basse et pas c'est pas
simplement les djihadistes c'est que
vous avez dans tous ces parcs animaliers
vous avez des populations peu des
éleveurs qui ont des seins nombre de
conflits qui sont abandonnés et
appartements où l'état n'est pas là et
bien évidemment que les djihadistes pas
simplement c'est pas simplement
l'armement et autres où la religion
c'est qu'ils exercent le foncier la
justice et l'est quand on parle
maintenant il faut savoir du mali comme
du burkina faso on parle des capitales
on parle de bamako on parle de ouaga
mais les trois quarts du pays s'il y
avait plus personne n'y a plus de
pouvoir régalien des états est ce qu'on
n'a pas perdu de vue aussi côté français
l'objectif réel de cette intervention
était simplement de repousser ou bien de
vaincre et djihadistes ou encore d'
asseoir la démocratie à bamako oui seria
il ya un mélange de tout mais je pense
que la france aussi elle est un peu dans
un anachronisme historique ça vient
c'est un peu la france qui pense encore
que voilà accéder à ces militaires mais
elle peut aussi gérer les problèmes
politiques des pays à voir ses hommes
des francophiles et homme qui lui
ressemble elle est un peu toujours un
peu dans la françafrique et quand on
parle à des mêmes des militaires qui ont
participé abarkan 18 1 me dit oui
vraiment là on a été on se croyait
encore un peu chez nous dans cette
région est en fait ça nous échappe
complètement et du coup au bout d'un
moment la france comme d'habitude a
voulu faire tout faire et devant
derrière au dessus au sein des pouvoirs
de ces pays a entraîné les européens et
c'est là où il ya vraiment un problème
de fond on va écouter une autre manière
de résumer tout ce qu'on vient dire ce
divorce entre mali et armée française
écouter master soumi le raconter ce
rappeur malien qui n'a pas sa langue
dans sa poche
ça fait huit ans que la française et au
mali venu pour combattre
des chars des grenades
armani malgré ses moyennes à geel
continuer finit pas et la situation se
dégrade de pazzapa la grande partie
échappe au contrôle de l'état malgré la
prime allait minustah pour pas la
présence française au mali a échoué les
maliens damon l'armée française de
dégager faudra-t-il se trouver au
préalable un placement contrat qui s'est
tourné vers la russie comme nouveaux
alliés six vaccins pour faire la guerre
noté mme hollis si wagner c'est pour
éliminer les bandits mais si wagner
c'est pour faire le vigile ici wanner
bague je suis plus fait porter gaies
sneg
mascottes sumi qui nous résume la
première partie de l'émission et qui
nous annonce la deuxième c'est juste
après un flash d'information c'est le
journal sur france 24
france info et france 24 présente
[Musique]
suite du monde dans tous ses états en
continu de faire le bilan de
l'intervention française au mali avec
vous antoine glaser journaliste écrivain
spécialiste de l'afrique auteur du livre
le piège africains de macron chez fayard
dit tout donc à présent n'est nayem
comment le mali en est-il arrivé là le
mali un piège sécuritaire vous le voyez
un pays enclavé 12 millions d'habitants
un territoire deux fois plus grand que
la france avec ce fleuve le niger qui
traverse le pays il ya en fait deux mali
le mali vers autour de bamako avec la
savane 9 malien sur 10 il y habite un
mali à richard mallie agricole et le
nord du mali dans le sahel aux portes du
sahara une zone quasiment désertique qui
a toujours été un carrefour des changes
zone de tous les trafics drogue armes
clandestins difficilement contrôlée par
l'état dans c'est dans cette zone que
l'on retrouve la question trois règles
et c'est de ce normal et que se sont
élancés les groupes jihadistes vers les
pays voisins une menace que la présence
militaire française n'a pas réussi à
endiguer les mouvements djihadistes
antoine glaser chou nourrissent des
affrontements entre communautés bien sûr
bien sûr faut quand même bien distinguer
le djihadisme au départ d'al qaïda du
maghreb islamique qui était quand même
génial gspc algérien qui ont exporté
dans les pays voisins ou nord de ces
pays finalement leur propre leurs
propres problèmes avec des jihadistes et
puis quand la france a implosé la libye
en 2011 entre on connaît le kadhafi ont
d'ailleurs en allant un peu plus loin
que la résolution parce que c'était
protéger plutôt les populations de
benghazi mais finalement c'est la france
car entraîner tous ses partenaires etc a
implosé de la libye et touareg qui était
dans l'armée de kadhafi sont redescendus
chez eux et on dit ben voilà nous
maintenant on veut la france nous avait
promis l'indépendance depuis de gaulle
et donc ils ont dit voilà maintenant on
va créer l'azawad et à ce moment là ils
se sont alliés comme il pouvait pas
faire ça sol qui se sont alliés à al
qaïda du maghreb islamique et ce chef
yat rallye est un touareg chef touareg
est ici alliés open au centre du mali
qui lui qui rêvait de créer le front de
libération du macina c'est pour ça que
je parle du retour des empires ii
neuvième siècle et donc c'est eux les
djihadistes mais simplement ils se
nourrissent des problèmes
intercommunautaires ils se nourrissent
des problèmes entre des peuls les dogons
entre les agriculteurs et les éleveurs
et on voit bien maintenant le risque
c'est qu'il ya une certaine en
particulier parmi les armées européennes
ou autres en disant ouais c'est la faute
des peules parce que c'est vrai que les
peules souvent et c'est eux qui vont
pourquoi ils m'ont vers les djihadistes
parce qu'ils sont abandonnés dans des
parcs admis animalier ils sont
abandonnés et ils sont ils sont beaucoup
plus transhumants avec toutes leurs leur
élevage et à ce moment là c'est des
problèmes socio économiques de ces pays
est dû au camp nou on parle nous pardon
de religion et autres missions dans des
problèmes inter communautaire social
économique des jeunes qui voient là ne
venant pas de boulot etc et qui peuvent
être pris en charge comme ça dans des
villages par des djihadistes qui leur
propose d'abord de faire du transport et
ensuite ils ont une kalach dans les
mains à ses difficultés économiques
s'ajoutent désormais l'embargo imposé
par les voisins d'afrique de l'ouest
cédéao so lu ment mais franchement là je
suis allé récemment et dans l'union la
2d association des maliennes en france
cia sait il ya les maliens en france qui
sont à mon avis ont dit 600 milles mais
sont peut-être plus proche de 700 à 800
milles ils ne peuvent plus envoyer
l'argent à leur famille s'est bloquée
par la bceao et à ce moment là dans la
banque centrale des états d'afrique de
l'ouest les états d'afrique de l'ouest
dans un premier temps c'est vrai que le
pouvoir à bamako a dit voilà c'est ça
leur a donné encore plus d'un sursaut
souverainiste nationaliste en dix ans il
y en a marre aussi du franc cfa et sert
à la bceao des chefs d'état de la région
mais à terme c'est vrai que tant qu'ils
peuvent payer les salaires ça va bien
mais quand sont vraiment étrangler c'est
pour ça d'ailleurs qu'ils vont chercher
qui vont en iran qui vont au cada
apparemment le qatar a promis de payer
un hôpital il essaie de diversifier leur
partenariat pour sortir de ce set c'est
étranglement financier mais oui en froid
avec leurs voisins ouest africains
revenus aussi du partenariat avec la
france les maliens se tournent de plus
en plus vers l'étranger et notamment
vers la russie pour leur sécurité c'est
désormais aux mercenaires du groupe
bruce wagner que s'en remettre les
dirigeants de la junte malienne on voit
ça en images avec nicolas bertrand pour
français vision
juste à côté de l'aéroport de bamako ce
camp militaire a vu le jour en quelques
semaines à côté un mur d'enceinte
flambant neuf courts sur des centaines
de mètres en s'approchant nous
distinguons quelques dizaines de soldats
à l'entraînement des blindés de
fabrication russe et un hélicoptère de
transport de troupes russes lui aussi
les villageois des alentours ont eux
mêmes été surpris à abobo le camp est
très grand ça commence ici et ça va
jusqu'aux murs de l'aéroport la poule à
alors s'agit-il d'un camp construit à la
hâte pour héberger des mercenaires du
groupe paramilitaire russe wagner pour
les spécialistes qui ont étudié les
cartes satellites de la zone il y a pas
de doute oui ce qu'on semble être la
base arrière de wagner son espèce de
point d'entrée au mali on est sur des
imans à 100% qu'il ya eu un déploiement
de plusieurs centaines de miliciens de
wagner depuis novembre on nous ya 450
aujourd'hui depuis ce camp les hommes de
wagner se seraient déployés discrètement
dans le centre et le nord du pays les
voici sur des photos amateurs dont la
ville de ségou pour se déplacer wagner
utilisent des véhicules de l'armée russe
et malienne c'est ce que dit avoir filmé
c'est habitants il préfère rester
anonyme voilà ça c'est l'ingénieur que
moi même j'ai filmé qui va sur les
véhicules drapeau russe tennessee dit
c'est la russe c'est sûr que c'est des
troupes reste
convalescent là bas mais il ya d'autres
véhicules qui s'en sert mais on sait pas
si c'est désarmant
jusqu'à présent les autorités maliennes
ont toujours nié avoir fait appel au
groupe wagner elles admettent simplement
avoir reçu de l'aide de formateurs de
l'armée russe et reçu des armements
à travers wagner est ce la russie qui
est désormais présente au mali interrogé
sur cette question vladimir poutine
répond par la négative écoutez c'était
lors de sa conférence de presse au
kremlin avec emmanuel macron la
fédération suisse n'a rien à voir avec
les entreprises militaires privées qui
opèrent au mali
l'état russe n'a rien à faire avec cela
c'est déjà la vue d'une présence antoine
dr wagner sait où ce n'est pas l'état
russe mais bien l'état c'est bien j'ai
indiqué un diplomate qui disait un truc
est très juste et autant en ukraine
c'est vraiment de la lumière poutine
joueur d'échecs c'est une confrontation
directe en afrique c'est le joueur de go
la chinoise ou japonaise ça veut dire si
l'encerclement à bas bruit avec avec
wagner en fait il ya tout un modus
operandi d'abord la russie officiel
livre de l'armement ses environs des
hélicoptères en particulier au niveau du
mali ensuite vous avez effectivement un
groupe privé wagner mais surtout pour
assurer la sécurité de bamako du régime
est haute ensuite vous avez des
géologues parce que la force de wagner
c'est un autofinancement russe à bas
prix parce que finalement ils se payent
directement sur limoux c'est ça qu'on a
gagné les russes de télévision elle
encore centrafrique si la géopolitique
vous avez en même temps que comme en
centrafrique quand ils sont dans les
mines mais quasiment officiellement donc
y en même temps des russes officiels qui
sont dans les mines la géologie est
aussi l'ex onatra richesses minières du
le directement et puis au bout d'un
moment je veux dire c'est évident que
mais ils sont même les français mais il
se demande pourquoi on n'a pas fait ça
depuis des années ça veut dire c'est
vraiment un jeu de go c'est vraiment à
bas bruit une présence comme ça et à
terme il ya une installation économique
importante c'est une pierre dans le
jardin de la minus mal l'onu il faut le
rappeler qu'il s'est beaucoup investie
avec quelques onze mille casques bleus
présents au mali dans le royaume de la
minus ma normalement pendant très
longtemps des textes et barkan qui était
la force réaction de réaction rapide de
la minus masia petit arcane on se
demande qui va assurer déjà s'il ya
vraiment des problèmes et puis oui les
mines de réassurance moment de la
protection de ces deux c'est fort de ces
casques bleus absolument et en plus il
faut savoir que on est dans une période
aussi aux nations unies il ya vraiment
des tensions c'est à dire toutes les
résolutions
préparer effet que la france voulait
faire voter contre le mali à chaque fois
vous avez un double veto russe et
chinois on est dans une nouvelle période
historique ça veut dire même les
opérations de maintien de la paix qui
était jusqu'à présent plus ou moins
contrôlés par la france les chinois s'y
intéressent donc à mon avis dans cette
région on est au début d'une sorte de
géo nouvelle géostratégie moi je dirais
pas nouvelle guerre froide ça n'a pas de
sens parce que vous avez les turcs vous
avez vous avez le monde entier en
afrique c'est là c'est la mondialisation
club de l'afrique que la france n'a pas
vraiment vu et on est en ayant une
structure comme barkan beaucoup trop à
l'ancienne il n'y a pas que l'onu à être
aujourd'hui impliqué est sur la sellette
l'europe aussi fortement incité par la
france aujourd'hui l'échec français
c'est aussi l'échec européen julien
gaspard le tout vous qui êtes pour
france télévisions à bruxelles où une
dizaine de pays européens étaient
engagés aux côtés de la france au mali
dont l'opération takouba et paris
avaient beaucoup misé sur cette mission
pour développer un premier modèle de
défense européenne commune mais malgré
cette présence est bien les européens
n'ont pas réussi à empêcher des coups
d'état à répétition et la situation
s'est détériorée à tel point qu'en
janvier et bien la junte militaire au
pouvoir a congédié les forces danoises
qui était présente au mali plus
généralement ce retrait démontre aussi
la perte d' influence des européens en
afrique au profit d'autres puissances
comme la chine ou la russie à l'image
des milices du groupe wagner qui sont
présentes dans de nombreux pays dont le
mali à leur côté européen on minimise
cet échec l'échec il est d'abord côté
malien il n'est pas à mettre à ceux qui
viennent apporter leur soutien confie un
haut responsable militaire et pas
question d'abandonner le sahel les
européens vont désormais se réorganiser
des militaires vont être redéployés au
niger et au delà de cet aspect
sécuritaire et bien les européens
promettent de renforcer leurs
investissements en matière de
développement économique de santé
d'éducation de transition numérique
c'était tout l'enjeu de ce sommet qui
s'est déroulée à bruxelles pendant deux
jours avec l'union afrique la task force
takouba antoine glaser et elle s'est
voulue un exemple autant qu'un embryon
de défense européenne ça porte un coup
ça aujourd'hui au projet survie c'est
évident c'est évident que quand vous
discutez off avec des diplômes d'autres
diplomates européens ils ont peur de se
retrouver dans une affaire françafrique
et on voit bien d'ailleurs est ce que
vous avez entendu bout des italiens des
espagnols ou même des allemands
s'exprimer sur ce qui se passait là bas
ils sont très prudents la secrétaire
d'état aux affaires étrangères
allemandes est allée elle-même voir
qu'est ce qui se passe à bamako et c'est
vrai que takouba une sur le plan
juridique s'était bizarrement monter
parce que si d'abord une un cadre pays
quatre français avec finalement chaque
pays des éleveurs il adhéra la
coopération bilatérale donc au bout d'un
moment ça devient compliqué quand les
les danois n'ont pas reçu de de feu vert
du de la junte malienne audio ben vous a
pas donné le feu vert aux vous étiez le
vendrait du bon vouloir de rama contre
les moyens de la noire entre nous quand
il ya des estoniens là bas pourquoi les
estoniens parce qu'il ya 300 soldats
militaires des forces spéciales
françaises en estonie sur le front russe
c'est tout ça on est dans la
géostratégie du donnant-donnant a bien
évidemment retournement en arrière nous
sommes le 2 février 2013 vous l'évoquez
à l'entâme de cette émission antoine
glaser moins d'un mois à l'époque après
l'engagement des forces françaises pour
faire reculer les djihadiste au mali
françois hollande est accueilli en
libérateur à tombouctou le président
français qui évoque alors le plus beau
jour de sa vie politique
accueil triomphal pour le président
français
françois hollande son nom est scandé par
une foule en liesse tombouctou libéré et
ses habitants salue la france
la france c'est parce que c'est la
france qui a pu sauver le monde entier
ce n'est pas les magiciens
des plantes soir on a un peu plus tôt ce
matin un avion militaire français ouvre
ses portes protocole oblige le président
malien par intérim en sort le premier
puis françois hollande tout un symbole
le président français foulent le sol de
la grande ville du nord mali reprises
cette semaine aux groupes islamistes par
les forces françaises et maliennes
aux côtés de françois hollande plusieurs
ministres dont laurent fabius a clamé
lui aussi
les larmes du ministre des affaires
étrangères à ton goût retour et une
journée historique
de marc antoine glaser on pourra
sécuriser le sahel et la menace qui a
dix qui s'étend désormais jusqu'au golfe
de guinée si l'on n'est pas au mali à
mon avis c'est pas une question de
djihadisme c'est vraiment une question
de social économique et un des problèmes
intercommunautaires on est encore une
fois dans une nouvelle période
historique
postcoloniale et c'est vraiment la
gestion des populations de leurs
ressources et c'est pas du tout quelle
que soit la puissance extérieure qui
pourrait en faire quoi que ce soit pour
l'ensemble de ce pays ça reste vraiment
ça va être vraiment de ça ld saharien
qui vont s'arranger entre eux et où par
mais je veux dire c'est pas avec des
interventions extérieures vous allez
régler les problèmes merci antoine
glaser d'avoir été avec nous se rappelle
aussi de votre ouvrage de pièges
africains de macron chez fayard et merci
à vous d'avoir suivi cette émission on
se retrouve non pas la semaine prochaine
mais dans trois semaines et d'ici là sur
nos sites internet franceinfo.fr france
24 points comme raï bonne journée vous
[Musique]